this video is sponsored by fabulous I
don't remember precisely where I heard
this particular story I don't remember
who was supposed to be there but there's
one old tale about Bruce Lee where he
was at a bar or a club or something with
a friend and they noticed this massively
muscular Bouncer and the friend exclaims
Bruce look at that that guy's just
packed with muscle perhaps expecting
Bruce Lee to be impressed or perhaps
intimidated and Bruce just answers sure
but can he use it
it seems that Bruce Lee was aware of
maxic and Monty saldo and their Max
solding system of building muscle this
was a muscle building system that didn't
rely on using heavy weights or typical
resistance training instead it relied on
the integral link between muscle and the
human brain
[Music]
foreign
just to be clear I don't buy into
everything I'm about to talk about here
there are definitely some outlandish
claims but I do think that it definitely
points to something interesting and this
is what I'm all about I love looking at
unusual way to potentially tap into
greater human performance
muscle control taught the practitioners
the max oldests to take total conscious
control over the major muscle groups of
the body followers such as Billy Ralph
use the system to develop physiques that
arguably rival that of some Modern
bodybuilders long before steroids became
freely available others used the
techniques to pull off incredible Feats
of superhuman strength even Harold
Houdini himself may have used lessons
passed on from Mexican contemporary
Joseph the mighty Adam grinstein to
perform some of his more unusual
displays
Concepts survived To This Day filming
Stan Lee's Superhumans modern strongman
and candidate for strongest man alive at
the time pound for pound Dennis Rodgers
discovered that he was able to recruit
more muscle fibers than a typical person
when bending iron and expressing
strength in other ways
so what's going on what do all these
things have in common and what can we
learn from this to apply to our own
training as I've discussed on this
channel in the past having muscle is
simply not enough you must also have the
ability to utilize that muscle that
means being able to send a strong signal
from the brain to actively engage the
motor units it also means being able to
utilize the correct muscles to move the
body in the right way for the job at
hand
so let's start with that latter example
as it's much simpler this is
proprioception knowing where your body
is in space and being able to move it
mindfully this is important when
executing any movement properly you
cannot perform a deadlift or kettlebell
swing for example if you don't
understand how to hinge the hips do you
know how to tilt your pelvis can you
retract your scapula these seemingly
arbitrary requirements are crucial for
being able to move confidently and to
avoid injury they're also necessary for
learning a host of new skills but
unfortunately due to inactivity many of
us simply don't know how to perform
those actions the next level of this is
being able to produce precise movements
when throwing a punch for example you
must use a series of smaller movements
in the correct sequence that means
driving through the foot talking the
hips and core and throwing the punch you
need to do this whilst relaxing the rest
of the body particularly the antagonist
muscles that fight against the movement
if you can relax the biceps fully while
throwing a punch it'll make the punch
faster and stronger than if you're
fighting resistance from your own body
and this way you can generate more power
from less muscle
a related concept from bodybuilding is
the Mind muscle connection this is the
ability to sense which muscles are doing
the work during a given Movement by
developing a sense of what a muscle
contraction should feel like a
bodybuilder can ensure they create
muscle damage metabolic buildup and
mechanical tension in the desired muscle
this leads to Greater growth and
definition muscle control takes this to
another level a Max oldest can go so far
as to pop individual muscles Contracting
them while keeping every other muscle
group completely relaxed an example of
this is if you look at my forearm here I
can tense my form contract it without
moving my hand or my biceps and this is
something that you can learn with any
muscle group and if you can eventually
get that kind of control without your
whole body in theory you could far more
accurately control your movements it's
got to the point where sometimes if I
feel a pain in my lower back I can
actually intentionally contract and then
relax the muscle that's hurting and
sometimes that can help with any
spasming of course one of the most
famous examples of muscle control is the
PEC dance I can do something similar
with my tricep now where I tense my
tricep
that's the bicep
that's the tricep the idea would be that
they could then take this kind of muscle
control and apply it to their training
so that they could truly isolate those
muscles try Contracting your tricep
without Contracting your bicep and
you'll find it's very hard to do the
reverse is also true this shows how
you're fighting against self-resistance
during movements like pull-ups and
tricep kickbacks when throwing a ball or
a punch
if you want to learn muscle control or
just generally learn to move your body
better then you need to practice
regularly like anything and this is
where today's sponsor fabulous comes in
fabulous the number one self-care app to
help you build better habits and achieve
your goals so fabulous is a habit
tracking app basically you put in here
your daily routine all the things you
want to do regularly and then it reminds
you to do those things it provides
encouragement and it makes you far more
likely to achieve those goals fabulous
also does a lot more than that though
you can also take on personalized
Journeys which are provided by experts
and guide you through routines and
habits that are proven to improve your
health and well-being you'll get
challenges and letters to encourage you
on the way it's like having a digital
coach in your pocket there's also
communities where you can support one
another in your different goals the
presentation is also absolutely
beautiful which doesn't hurt and the
community is now over 30 000 strong so
they must be doing something right start
building your ideal daily routine today
and the first 100 people who click the
link below and sign up will get 25
percent off of their subscription thanks
again so much to Fabulous for sponsoring
this video and thanks to you guys now
let's get on with the show
but if you can completely relax the
antagonist muscles you can deliver much
more Force you're moving with the
efficiency of that highly trained
athlete but in every single movement
that you perform in muscle control the
ability to fully relax a muscle then is
just as important as to be able to fully
contract it and this is arguably even
more difficult to accomplish take a
moment right now to observe how much
tension you're currently carrying
unnecessarily in terms of what's
actually going on inside the body when
you move a single muscle group
independently or can't this is to do
with your neural maps and the way that
you've made them more or less efficient
so if you try and move one toe you might
find that a lot of your other toes move
as well and this is actually due to the
fact that you're so unused to moving
them on their own that the neural Maps
the Pathways in your brain have become
fused so that firing one fires the next
just like when you say A you think B
these things have become so connected
through rope repetition that you now
can't move your toes independently and
the same thing can happen with your
muscles but through practice and by
feeling them and gently working them you
can gradually set separate and create
new neural Pathways to more precisely
engage the different muscles that you
need to but true muscle control goes
even further Beyond because it's not
just about engaging and relaxing the
correct muscles it's also about the
extent to which you contract those
muscles because a muscle is made up of
hundreds of thousands of muscle fibers
grouped together as motor units a motor
unit is a group of muscle fibers
controlled by a single nerve motor units
vary in size from small to large the
smaller units containing more of the
slow twitch muscle fibers that are
significantly more energy efficient and
don't tire out as quickly the larger
motor units are primarily comprised of
fast and super fast fibers but are
rapidly fatigued when you send a signal
from your brain to engage the muscle the
strength of that neural Drive will
determine the percentage of motor units
that will be used but the order always
Remains the Same small to large this is
henneman's size principle so I've tried
to explain this on the channel in the
past from the comments it seems that
people don't always understand how this
works so come up with a unique way to
demonstrate it so if you take these
little ball bearings and you imagine
that the larger ball bearings are your
large motor units with the fast twitch
muscle fiber that can deliver a lot of
power and then these smaller ball
bearings are the more energy efficient
smaller motor units that control your
slower twitch muscle fiber so if I want
these to move then I can blow on them
if I want just the smaller ball bearings
to move then I can blow on them really
lightly like so
however if I want the big ball bearings
to move then I have to blow on them
really hard and that's going to also
move the smaller ball bearings so as you
can see it's possible to move the
smaller ball bearings without moving the
big ones but the reverse is not true now
in terms of what we can manage a lot of
us are only capable of a small breath we
can only engage a certain number of
those motor units the trained athlete
can be a little bit harder but using
muscle control techniques and Old Time
strong man training it is possible
potentially to recruit far more to
basically blow this massive gust and set
them all flying off the table and that's
what we're really interested in
achieving here so like this
foreign
it's to see me breathe gently on stuff
right now guys it is worth mentioning
that maxic and his ilk were marketers
they were trying to sell programs and
books and so of course it was beneficial
for them to come up with a unique
Training Method that sounded too good to
be true I'm sure there's some of you
already calling BS politely in the
comments down below that said the
ability to individually move muscles as
they do kind of speaks for itself and
from the little bit that I've read and
experimented with this is relatively
easy to learn and it certainly is
founded on logical Concepts it also has
a lot in common with other ideas from
other training methods in particular
with things like internal martial arts
such as Tai Chi or Qigong these
practices are not just about performing
the movement but the way that you
execute it about the order the sequence
of muscle contractions for example in
Tai Chi you have the four Tai Chi
energies Peng Liu ji and Anne these
describe four ways of what announced it
pushing Peng is an uprooting force that
comes as though from a spring imagine
the way you might get underneath the
heavy ball to throw it the upper body is
relaxed and the force comes from the
legs which must maintain their structure
and is condensing energy the way you
push yourself up from a chair using your
hands on its arms behind you you aren't
just pressing down as hard as you can
you're creating attention through your
entire back such that you're able to
lift yourself upwards to be crystal
clear I am not good at Tai Chi do not
look at me as an example of how to
perform your Tai Chi forms I did it
years ago for one year and I was
terrible at it even back then but what I
do know is that it's not just about the
movements it's about relaxing the body
as you go through the movements it's
about maintaining forms that have
inherent structure it's about driving
power from the hips etc etc hence
internal martial arts Qigong goes far
deeper and uses seemingly static poses
with concentrating breath work to gain
greater control over the body but at an
advanced level some practitioners claim
that they can even control their own
organs and even aspects of their hormone
production if that sounds a little bit
far-fetched an esoteric then consider
that Wim Hof taught himself to control
his own sympathetic nervous system so if
he can do that then why not and this is
where the Houdini connection comes in
Houdini learned how to regurgitate
specific objects by swallowing them on a
string and then pulling them back up
using this opportunity to feel the
muscles of the stomach working and to
gradually take control over them this is
how all performers achieve this act and
similarly a technique taught by the
mighty atom is what enabled him to
contract his abs so hard that he was
able to take a punch like a Shaolin monk
coincidentally Bruce Lee also
demonstrated the ability to contract
individual muscles in his forearm at
will so how do you go about developing
this muscle control well now we're a
thousand eight hundred words deep and
it's getting late so how about you
subscribe and I'll make a follow-up
video soon a very little primer Max
holding techniques involve placing a
hand on the muscle during movement to
get a better idea for how they would
feel when Contracting muscle control is
then practiced in front of a mirror in
many cases in the case of learning to
contract your forearm muscles all you
have to do
is think about squeezing an apple or
moving your fingers but don't actually
do it and as you do hold your hand on
the forearm to feel the contraction and
then just learn to do that over time the
forearm's a great one because you can
actually watch yourself doing it and
there are reports that Bruce Lee
demonstrated this little trick as well
once again demonstrating his interest in
muscle control
more gentle muscle controllers combined
with Peak contractions body leveraging
exercises a form of calisthenics are
then performed to very mindfully put
this control into practice the original
text by maxic Otto Arco and others are
available freely and out of copyright I
also recommend the YouTube channel
Golden Era Bookworm overcoming
isometrics are a perfect tool for
increasing neural drive as they allow
for a much longer maximum contraction
meanwhile quasi-isometrics are extremely
slow repetitions that are useful for
teaching much finer more precise control
over the amount of force you wish to
exert what I call strength finesse
and in a passive quasi isometric you
contract only those muscles strictly
necessary for the movement relaxing
everything else sound familiar also
simply practice being more mindful of
your precise movements during exercise
and I will say that in order to truly
make the most of all this you also need
to develop your working memory to allow
for greater awareness of multiple muscle
parts working in unison again I'll come
back to all of this
the point of this video was to act as an
introduction to what I believe is a very
unexplored Avenue for enhancing Human
Performance to becoming super functional
if you're interested in training in a
way that improves more than just your
physique more than just your max
strength on a few lifts then you might
like my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system that incorporates
things like overcoming isometrics as
well as quasi isometrics and even a
mindful meditation used prior to
workouts to help increase that mind
muscle connection I'll leave a link to
that in description down below it comes
with an 80 plus page ebook as well as
over two hours of instructional video
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and I'll see you
next time
bye for now